kourtney kardashian is shutting down
pregnancy rumors this is insane on
thursday the reality star shared selfies
from inside her closet looking fab in a
crop top and red skirt in the comment
section several fans suggested the 42
year old was pregnant with baby number
four one fan simply wrote she's pregnant
courtney was quick to shut down the
speculation writing quote i'm a woman
with a body i'm just like living life of
course the push founder is already a mom
to the three kiddos she shares with ex
scott disick sons mason and rayne and
daughter penelope
productions penelope's like don't worry
productions
i mean i think you just gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day courtney is
currently dating blink 182 drummer
travis barker and things are moving fast
i love it a source recently told et
quote scott has gotten more used to the
idea that courtney and travis's
relationship is serious but it's not his
favorite subject of discussion another
source told et quote courtney and travis
really recognize now more than ever how
special their relationship is and how
fortunate they are to spend their time
together whether it's just the two of
them with friends or with their families
whatever happens happens
[Music]